So lemme just get this outta the way now.
Um, yes, I'm limping and yes, I'm sitting.
Uh, so yesterday I was literally just standing on the court
but rebounding for my son and I turned around
and my knee buckles inward.
And so I don't know what's going on yet.
We'll figure it out. I'm only 41.
I didn't feel like I've hit the age yet
where I get hurt standing.
So here we are.
Um,
Doesn't get any better, does it, Greg?
Okay, great. Thank you.
I know it's pretty minor compared to what I know some
of you're going through right now, so I, I get that.
But we'll see how this week goes.
Um, what, what it did, this was interesting.
I was wrestling with that this morning.
It's revealed some selfishness in my heart
because we had a ski trip planned in a couple weeks.
And, and so it's like, why am I more upset about that than
other things that I should be upset about?
You know, just a little selfishness in my heart there.
So appreciate your prayers for all that as we go forward.
But, uh, I need to sit down for at least today.
We'll see how that goes. But it's still a great Sunday.
We're kicking off a new sermon
series called First Things First.
And, uh, maybe you're new to our church today.
We're grateful that you would choose to,
to take this step to be with us.
Uh, let me just say I'm proud of you for taking that step.
It's a big deal as you're trying
to start some new rhythms in life, uh, this new year, maybe.
Uh, we're thankful for you.
Don't worry about six months from now,
like that's the long way off.
Just the next step. That's all
you need to worry about today.
We'd love to help you with that.
So, uh, there's QR code
and then there's a new here area out there if you
want to let us know who you are.
So we can help you in that way as we go.
But what do we mean by first things first as we talk about
that series?
Well, as you saw, our version involves rocks and sand.
By the way. It's amazing how focused the little boys are
right now as we go through this series.
They saw that and we see this rock here.
It's not a potato, by the way.
Um, but,
but with these first things, what we're talking about,
what we're wanting to do is go back
to the basics theologically.
So Jude one three calls this The faith Once
for All Delivered to the Saints.
He says, it's our common salvation as he called it, meaning
the basic core of our beliefs as Christians.
Like what makes us the doctrines that make us
distinctly Christian.
In fact, it's what Ephesians chapter four, uh, verses four
through six describe, there is one body,
one spirit, just as you were called to the one hope
that belongs to your call.
One lord, one faith, one baptism, one God,
and Father of all whose overall through all and in all.
So that's the idea we're gonna get to.
And we need these reminders
'cause there's a lot of religions out there
that will teach similar things to what we talk about
as Christians when you talk about being unselfish
or loving others or that there's an afterlife
or that there's a God who helps them if they do the
right kinds of things.
But if we believe that Jesus is the only way to God,
if we believe that, that he is that, then we need
to understand why.
And then we also need to understand what those beliefs are
that we would say are true.
Who even is this God that we talk about?
That's what we're gonna get to because here's the reality.
Every one of us, every person in the world is a theologian,
has beliefs about God.
They're either believing the right
and true things that we get from God's word,
or they're filling the gaps with their own made up versions
of what they hope God is like
or what they want him to be like.
And so we're gonna look at what God's word says.
Now, we're not gonna be able to say everything about each
one of these beliefs.
I only have a, a short few minutes on a Sunday.
Uh, that's why just as a side note, on Wednesday nights,
we're gonna come back together as one
of our equipping classes on Wednesdays.
We're calling it Digging Deeper
where we're gonna take this topic of whatever Sunday was.
Dig deeper into it, do q and a talk a lot more.
We'll have a lot more time there.
So if you're interested in, in more about
what we're saying each Sunday, Wednesday nights that class,
it will be a good one for you.
But our hope here in this series is
that whether this is something you're familiar with already,
like all these doctrines are gonna be old hat to you,
or maybe you're completely new to this.
You've never heard any of these things before.
Our hope in this is that you will come to know God
and you'll come to rejoice your in your faith more than ever
before, simply because we know who he is better than before.
Here's how we're also gonna take this
toward the end of the series.
And really at times throughout, you'll hear me
and others do this, we're gonna touch on some,
some lower tier Christian beliefs that,
that Christians hold at times can and
and do hold things that are not essential.
Like we're gonna major on the majors, but,
but really there are some things that we need to talk about
that are not as essential.
We're gonna see a couple things that'll make our church
distinct, but we're also going to see how we should interact
with other Christians who also agree on the major things,
but differ a little bit on some
of the less important things.
Even in this room today. We hopefully all agree on the big
rock doctrines of the Christian beliefs that we would die
for, that people in history have died for.
But there's even some smaller rocks
and sand among us in this room.
The way we see things a little bit differently, things
that are not gospel level issues, right?
Things that are not as clear in scripture
or even things that we can have freedom on the way we live
and choose to live our lives.
That's why when we look at the differences among those kinds
of things, that's why there's denominations.
That's why there's different churches.
We're not all the same.
There's even differing opinions on some
of those lifestyle choices we would make as far as
what we choose in our lives.
And so we have to ask how do we, how do we disagree?
Well, as believers, how do we work with people
that might differ on a couple little things,
but what we, we agree on the major things?
How can we do that?
Well, we're gonna do some of
that towards the end of this series.
But I wanna come back to, uh, as you saw in the video,
this jar that's sitting right here,
it's the one from the video.
When I talked about all those, what we call second
and third tier issues, beliefs,
we we're classifying those as the smaller rocks
and the sand.
When you think about those things
and you think about a jar,
we can't put those things in the jar first, right?
Like you, you think about, you put the sand in first.
You put the smaller rocks in first.
Then when you want to go put the big rocks in,
they won't fit right.
It would fill up most of the jar
and then the big rocks don't actually fit in.
So what we have to do is we have to put the primary things,
the first things in first,
the most important things in first.
Because if we focus on these lesser issues like preferential
things in our lives, or church practice concerns first,
or even political divides first,
we put those things in first that begins to crowd out all
of the big rock doctrines that we must have in the jar.
We've gotta put the big rocks in first.
Then all that other stuff fits
around those you see.
Now, full disclosure as we head into this series, I am
intimidated by this
because it, it is difficult to study
these massive concepts
and try to communicate them clearly
in a few minutes on a Sunday.
These are things that have been debated
for thousands of years.
Talked about and written books upon books.
And I'm gonna give you 30 minutes, right?
And so I'm intimidated by this.
That's why I'm leaning on a ton of resources.
So many people in the background helping
develop these things.
So just know this, that as we walk this road,
we're walking this road together.
Like I'm, I said I'm intimidated, yes, but also excited
because I'm gonna learn so much myself
as I study these things again,
to grow in our love for the Lord.
And so as we grow in this, as we understand more,
let's also though walk humbly.
'cause again, like I said, this has
been debated for thousands of years.
And so we need to walk humbly realizing where we are limited
and we need to walk in love where we, yes,
we're gonna hold our beliefs firmly,
but we also need to respect others' dignity when
we disagree on some things.
That's our hope as we go into this. So I hope you're ready.
Are you ready? We're about
to dive in over the next few weeks to this.
So here is our, our first big rock doctrine
that we put in the jar.
First is revelation.
Not the last book of the Bible.
Don't think we're going there, right? That's not it.
This is God's self revelation.
His revealing of who he is to us.
'cause here's the reality, unless God tells us about
himself, we don't know anything about him.
We know very little about him.
I should say, as you'll see here, we can't know him
in any other way unless he tells us who he is
and how we can know him.
That's why we start with this.
We don't start with the doctrine of God.
We start with the doctrine of revelation that he needs
to tell us who he is.
And thankfully he has.
And so turn with me to Psalm 19 to help us see that
Psalm 19, to help us see the how
and the why that he has revealed himself.
Psalm 19. Now this psalm was written by David, a man
who knew God's law very well,
but also spent a ton
of time when he was a young shepherd out
underneath the stars at night.
And you'll actually see both aspects of
that here in this psalm.
So look at Psalm 19 with me.
You'll be on the screen if you don't have it.
There's a copy of God's word underneath one
of the seats around you.
Here's Psalm 19.
The heavens declare the glory of God.
The sky above proclaims his handiwork.
Day to day, pours out speech, night
to night reveals knowledge.
There is no speech,
nor are there words whose voice is not heard.
Their voice goes out through all the earth
and the words to the end of the world in them.
He set a tent for the sun,
which comes out like a bridegroom leaving his chamber.
Like a strong man runs its course with joy.
It's rising is from the end of the heavens.
It's circuit to the end of them.
And there's nothing hidden from its heat.
The law of the Lord is perfect, reviving the soul.
The testimony of the Lord is sure, making wise the simple,
the precepts of the Lord are right, rejoicing the heart.
The commandment of the Lord is pure, enlightening the eyes,
the fear of the Lord is clean, enduring forever.
The rules of the Lord are true and altogether righteous.
More to be desired are they than gold.
Much even much fine gold, sweeter also than honey
and drippings of the honeycomb.
Moreover by them is your servant warned.
In keeping them there is great reward
who can discern his errors.
Declare me innocent from hidden faults.
Keep back your servant also from presumptuous sins.
Let them not have dominion over me,
then I shall be blameless
and innocent of great transgression.
Let the words of my mouth
and the meditation of my heart be acceptable in your sight.
Oh Lord, my rock
and my eye, redeemer God, that's our prayer today
as we meditate on your word for the next few minutes,
as we sing with our mouths in a moment, we,
we pray that that would be acceptable.
We know there's only one way.
We'll see that here, for that to be acceptable.
But God, our heart cry is to know you better.
And I pray we would see that through Psalm 19 today.
Open our eyes and our ears to see
and hear what you want us to see and hear today,
and to be doers of the word,
not hearers only in Jesus' name.
Amen. So did you see the two
distinct sections of Psalm 19?
They correspond with what is often described
as the two modes of God's self revelation.
I think there's three, actually.
We'll get to that a little bit later.
But, but first what we see is God's general
revelation of himself.
That's the first part here.
Genesis is the story of creation.
This kind of parallels that verses one through six
of Psalm 19 shows us God's general
revelation of himself.
His natural revelation.
I mean, just look at the language, right? You see it.
Verse one, the heavens constantly declare the glory of God.
How glorious God is the sky above it proclaims,
it shows God's creative handiwork.
Verse two, each day pours out a description of God.
It it's like in the morning,
it freely bubbles out of the sky.
In fact, that word, that word can be used for belch as well.
But we're not gonna go there today. Okay?
Uh, but that's the idea.
It pours out this description of God each night.
Also reveals, it tells, it declares knowledge about God.
This is just creation declaring.
And then verse three supports
that the nature's tell telling God's glory.
It says it's all audible everywhere
that those, it says words.
It's not words, it's not audible, right?
It's these words are going out to the ends of the earth
to declare who God is.
Just like the sun's heat covers the whole.
And this is objectively true, right? This is just nature.
When we look at creation, we can't help
but be stunned at how great God really is.
You know the song, right?
I don't wanna sing a solo, so you
better sing with me on this, right?
How great thou art?
Oh Lord, my God, please say,
when I in awesome wonder,
consider all the world's thy
hands have made.
I see the stars.
I hear the rolling thunder.
Thy power throughout the universe
displayed, then sings my soul,
my savior, your God to thee.
How great thou are.
How great thou then sings my
soul, my savior,
your God to thee.
How great thou
thou see, that's
what God's general revelation is intended to do.
It's intended to humble us before him.
Like how do you look around at the creation
and say, it's all about me.
How? How do I do that? Right? I love what John Piper said.
He said, it's all about the greatness of God,
not the significance of man.
God made man small
and the universe big to say something about himself.
You see that, right? And we know that intuitively.
But again, like how often do we still
make ourselves the center of the universe?
I'm so tempted to revolve everything around me.
My thoughts are often all about me.
My my actions are, are trying to work things
for my own advantage.
I get mad when my plans are interrupted. Hello. Right?
But let's just stop for a second
and consider how small we really are.
One person out of 8 billion people now
on a planet that is 25,000 miles around
in a galaxy that is 87,000 light years across,
which is one of millions of galaxies in the universe.
God made man small
and the universe big to say something about himself.
I To humble us, to remind us
that he is God and we're not.
And listen, let's just, that's good news, right?
I, I don't wanna be in charge of this whole thing.
I don't want any of you to be in charge of this whole thing.
This thing's way too big for God is,
and that's why Romans 1136 says this, for from him
and through him and to him are all things
to him be glory forever.
Amen. But here's, here's one
of the criticisms we get about this.
We're not just reading our knowledge of God.
Now back into creation.
That's what's often said, no.
This what we're talking about is objectively
and universally present.
Whether anyone who recognizes it or acknowledges it
or believes it or not, it is there.
Which is why the Apostle Paul can say
that all people are rightly condemned by their sin.
Whether they've heard the gospel or not.
'cause that's what Romans one 18 through 32 says,
for the wrath of God, there's only wrath of God towards sin.
So the wrath of God is revealed from heaven against all
ungodliness and unrighteousness of men who
by their unrighteousness, suppress the truth.
Here's why. For what can be known about God is plain to them
because God has shown it to them.
For his invisible attributes, namely his eternal power.
Divine nature have been clearly perceived
ever since the creation of the world
in the things that have been made.
So there are without excuse for,
although they knew God, they did not honor him as God
or give thanks to him,
but they became futile in their thinking.
And their foolish hearts were darkened, claiming to be wise,
they became fools
and exchanged the glory of the immortal God
for images resembling mortal man and birds and animals
and creeping things.
See, in our sin, we reject
what is plain about God in creation.
Instead turning to idols.
He goes on in chapter two to describe
how we reject even God's law that's written on our hearts,
that there's an intuitive nature, sense of God.
God designed us, designed creation to know that he's there.
That's why when you look at every culture,
there's some sense of religion.
There's some sense of a God, right?
It's because it's in here. It's out there. We see it.
We know intuitive. Something is there. But here's the thing.
Romans three goes on to say that just becoming more aware
of God is not the solution.
In other words, there's no natural theology
that can save a person.
The only solution is by putting on what John Calvin called,
the spectacles of faith.
The glasses of faith.
That's why we talked about general revelation so far.
General revelation must always be kept in submission to
what we saw next in Psalm 19.
Remember God's special revelation of himself.
So we saw God's general revelation.
Then we also, the shift in verse seven led us
to now see God's special revelation of himself.
Because you saw David start talking
about something different, right?
Creation, creation, creation, creation.
Then he started talking about God's law, the testimony
of the Lord, his precepts, his commandments, his rules.
What he's referencing there is what he had at the time,
which we know as the Torah, the first five books
of the Old Testament.
And so Israel at the time, all through history from
that time, they saw that the Torah as God's revelation
of himself through Moses, that God said, here's who I am,
here's what you're supposed to do.
But then over time it was added to developed.
As they added historical books,
they added prophecies from the prophets, wisdom literature.
Jesus and the apostles in their timeframe looked back
and they referenced all of that as scripture.
Everything that we have as our Old Testament
was the scriptures that Jesus and the apostles looked at
and said, that's God's word.
That's God's self revelation.
And so then among the early church, the apostles
who had been with Jesus, they were recording Jesus's life.
They were recording his ministry.
They were recording the letters that they were writing
to the churches under the inspiration of God's spirit.
And what they did is even that collection began to be seen
as God's self revelation, his authoritative word as well.
That's where we then get the 66 books that we now have
that we call God's word as well.
And again, this was necessary, right?
Because we needed him to tell us about himself
or else we wouldn't know him.
We could get some general ideas from creation,
but we couldn't know him unless he told us about himself.
But the question is, how did he do that?
How do we know that this is God's word?
Well, he did it through people.
He spoke through people.
This is what two Peter one verse 20
and 21 says, that no prophecy
of scripture comes from someone's own interpretation.
For no prophecy was ever produced by the will of man.
But men spoke from God
as they were carried along by the Holy Spirit.
God breathed out his word by leading people.
Even Peter himself.
Later in chapter three, he saw Paul, his writings
as scripture already.
He's a contemporary. They knew each other.
And he looked at Paul and he said, man, God was speaking
through Paul, this circumstances around here.
God spoke and this is scripture.
So notice something about scripture is
that it wasn't merely a person coming up with this stuff.
This was God speaking through people.
Now, he used their personality, he used their context.
But God, superintendent, every word,
meaning every word in scripture is there
because God wanted it to be there, even
by ensuring that we now have what he wants us to have today.
And listen, this even includes everyone's favorite
abandoned ship moment.
As you're reading through the Bible, the genealogies,
some of you're already, you know,
you're a week in committed to it.
February 8th, I'm done, right?
Because you hit those things
and you're like, why did, why did God put those in there?
Well, first of all, he didn't
put them in there to punish us.
They're an accurate historical record,
certainly at the very least.
But think about how God used families
to bring about the Messiah.
He fulfilled prophecies through lineages, genealogies
of people, families,
and all of it points us to God's providence
in the history of redemption.
That that it shows us how he brought about the good news
of Jesus at just the right time.
All that together, when you look at that,
they're talking about the Old Testament
and how it developed to bring about
that moment 2000 years ago when Jesus came.
All of that together is why Paul says in two Timothy three
15 that the sacred writings,
he's talking about the Old Testament.
At the time, the scriptures were able to make you wise
for salvation through Christ Jesus.
That this special revelation of God is able
to make you wise for salvation
through faith in Christ.
In other words, they show us the way,
even the Old Testament,
'cause that's what He's talking about, it points
us to Jesus.
God's special revelation is to reveal
salvation to his people.
That's why one of our anchoring, one of our values,
is anchoring truth.
That we prioritize God's word in everything we do
because it is what reveals who he is.
And it reveals salvation to us.
But listen, that's why scripture is so critical for each
of us to dig into ourselves.
Because you remember how Psalm 19 describes its effect, how?
How it affects us. It's true. It's right in everything.
Absolutely. But the scriptures also, it says
revives the soul.
It makes wise the simple. It rejoices the heart.
It enlightens the eyes. It endures forever.
It can even keep us from sinning
how again, because God breathed it out.
God inspired it to teach us about himself,
about his character in order to rebuke us when we sin,
to correct us the right direction,
and to train us how to live a life that's godly.
That's all from his words.
So that you heard it read earlier, two Timothy three 17,
the man of God may be complete, fully equipped
for every good work.
I, I can't say this enough.
Scripture is essential
for our growth in Jesus Christ.
It's how we see him,
which second Corinthians three says, when we see him, that's
how we're changed into his image.
So it's only through his word.
We cannot know God, how he desires us
to know him any other way.
We must hunger
and thirst for his word in here, of course,
but also on our own.
I love how Pastor Javier from Nicaragua said it
just a few weeks ago.
He said, the word of God must be the bread of life,
not the cake of
birthdays, right?
Tastes good every year,
once a year.
It's not the way it's supposed to be. It's the word.
It's the bread of life daily sustaining us. We need it.
Ask God for it. There's one more
piece of the puzzle here though.
And we saw that God shows his special power,
his eternal power, his divine nature
through general revelation.
And he lets us know who he is through special revelation.
But that special revelation only points us toward salvation.
And so God himself took it one step further in his
personal revelation of himself,
Personal, that he actually came,
not just told us about himself.
He actually came. You remember how David closed Psalm 19?
It was this messianic connote.
He says, oh Lord, Yahweh, my rock
and my redeemer.
David knew he needed a savior.
God had given his good word.
He'd pointed his people to salvation, even the Old Testament
by grace through faith.
He'd shown them who he is, his character.
But then what God would do later if a thousand years
after David is he would actually show up.
Here's who I am, here's what I'm about. But now I am here.
This is what we call the incarnation.
What we just celebrated a couple weeks ago with Christmas.
The incarnation where God, the Son, took on flesh
personally, came born as a baby, lived, died,
resurrected, ascended.
And he was personal. He was real.
He wasn't a ghost, he was real.
The Apostle John described it so well,
his experience with Jesus.
This is first John chapter one.
He says that which was from the beginning,
which we have heard, which we have seen with our eyes,
which we looked upon
and have touched with our hands concerning the word of life.
That's Jesus. The life was made manifest, evident, visible.
And we have seen it testified to it proclaimed
to you the eternal life, which was with the Father.
And it was made manifest to us that which we've seen
and heard, we proclaim also to you so
that you too may have fellowship with us.
Indeed, our fellowship is with the Father
and with his son Jesus Christ.
So get this. Not only did God
give us his word to direct us toward the way
of salvation, he also gave us the actual way
of salvation capital W Jesus Christ,
who John 14 says, I am the way, the truth in the life.
No one comes to the Father except through me.
Not only the way we see in scripture the way came
and made the way for us.
John one 14, the eternal word became flesh
and dwelt among us.
And we've seen His glory, glory
as the only son from the Father full of grace
and truth, full of saving grace, full of gospel truth.
And he did all of that church to save us.
His personal revelation was to save us.
He came to be
and to do what David foresaw back in Psalm 19,
to be the rock.
One Corinthians 10, four says that Jesus is to be what?
Then Galatians four says the redeemer, listen to this.
When the fullness of time had come,
God sent forth his son, born of woman born under the law to
redeem those who were under the law so
that we might receive adoption as sons.
Listen, this redeemer is the only way you
and I can be acceptable in God's sight.
It's not merely by being a better person
by changing this words that you used to say or
or that thought process.
You change those things.
It's not merely by out balancing your good over your bad
because you can't,
no one can climb a ladder of good works to get to God.
But here's the thing, I know how quickly
I default back into that mode of thinking.
Like I know the gospel,
I preach the gospel, but my default
operating system is works.
And so when I sin, I run away from my heavenly Father.
Instead of run to him, I hide sin.
I don't confess to brothers and sisters 'cause I'm ashamed.
Why I if this God
who is love has revealed himself in love to pay for
that sin, then why do I still function the old way if I have
a redeemer who's done it all and covered it all?
Why do I still function as if I'm under the works?
Listen, friends, this is why we study theology.
It's not just cold and academic.
It's meant to help us know who he is,
to build and deepen the relationship that he has
graciously given us.
We don't deserve it. And yet he did it anyway.
And so my prayer today is that we would see him
as the glorious creator,
yes, that he is.
He's good to tell us about himself and who he is,
and we would long to know more about that.
But that also that he has been gracious enough
to become like us in order to save us.
May that truth, those truths stir our affections more
and more for him simply
because we know who he is now by his self revelation.